[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is I/O Live.
You just saw the
developer keynote
where Jason and team brought
you through the latest updates
to our developer
products and platforms.
Android, Google Assistant,
the web, material design,
machine learning, Firebase,
and AR core were all discussed.
We now have a few special
guests joining us to summarize.
First up is Dan from the Android
Developer Relations team.
OK, Dan.
There was a lot in
the Android section.
What are your highlights?
DAN GALPIN: I'm really looking
forward to hearing feedback
from developers around Android
Jetpack and Android Studio 3.2,
all part of our plan to make
Android development easier,
faster, and more testable.
Now, Jetpack builds
on the foundations
of architecture components
in the support library
to create an easy to use
toolbox that allows you to craft
a single code base
that runs on almost
all active Android devices.
Jetpack's work manager
is totally cool.
We've long needed a unified
API for scheduling constraint
triggered background tasks.
Well, Navigation combines with
Studio's navigation editor
to visualize and
implement the way apps
navigate between screens, easing
many developer pain points
in the process.
And Kotlin is so fun to use,
it's more popular than ever.
And Jetpack's KTX extensions
make it even better.
Now, speaking of our
tools, the Emulator
now starts up super fast
and supports snapshots.
Meanwhile, the
Studio and Play teams
are rethinking app
distribution with app bundles
and dynamic delivery,
allowing developers
to dramatically reduce app size.
And this is important because
the larger your app gets,
the less installs
you tend to get.
By rebuilding your
app as an app bundle,
Google Play's new
dynamic delivery
will only deliver the
code and resources
a specific device
needs, and it's
launching production use today.
And one more thing.
Starting today in
our Dev channel,
Chrome OS will have the
ability to securely run
Linux apps, which
means you can now try
Android Studio on Pixelbooks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Dan.
Next up is Wayne to talk about
Android Things and Google
Assistant.
Hey, Wayne, what's your summary?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Well, Timothy, it
starts with Android Things
graduating this week
from developer preview to
1.0, which is really exciting.
We're now ready to create
production devices with updates
to help developers build secure
internet of things devices.
You can use Android
Studio and everything
you know about Android
to write code, then
use our console to push updates
to your fleet of devices.
Jumping over to the
Google Assistant,
we now have over 500
million Assistant
enabled devices out there.
Every developer
should be thinking
about an assistant
action as a companion
experience to your
main app or website
that users can access
from a smart speaker,
a wireless device, or even
in the car, when they're not
using their phone or computer.
And you can share state between
your apps and your actions
easily, personalizing
it for users
and keeping track of any
subscriptions or purchases.
It's really easy to get
started building with actions
on Google, using tools
such as Dialogflow,
which uses machine
learning to make
building conversations easy.
We also introduced
some things to help
you get lots of people
engaged with your experience.
Action links are hyperlinks
you can use anywhere that point
directly into your action,
and they make it easier
to promote your actions.
We have action
notifications that
give you a way to let your
users know about new content
or features in your
assistant action.
These are particularly
cool because they
work on a phone or
any assistant device,
even if your users don't have
your Android app installed.
After someone engages
with your action,
you can now use
routine suggestions
to prompt them to add your
action to their routines,
such as waking up in the
morning or getting to work.
And one last thing
to note is in built
in intense, which are
a neat way of giving
the Assistant a deeper
understanding of what
your action can do so it
can bring you more traffic.
So in summary, lots of
new features, and now is
a great time to start
developing with our actions
on Google Platform.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Wayne.
Jumping over to web,
Meggin, tell us more
about what's been announced.
MEGGIN KEARNEY: Hi, Timothy.
So excited to be
here at I/O to get
to meet and talk with
all kinds of developers
from all over the world.
If you're a web developer or
just curious about the web,
this is the year
to find out more.
One area we're really excited
about is Progressive Web apps.
As you've heard,
Service Worker--
the API that makes
PWAs possible,
is now supported on
all major browsers.
We're also happy that
Lighthouse launched version 3.0,
as mentioned in the keynote.
Lighthouse analyzes
your site and tells you
how you can improve
your user's experience.
With 3.0, your
performance metrics
will be even more precise.
Also, I'm personally
very excited about AMP
and its continued
progress in making
it easier for developers
to build pages
that load instantly.
We're introducing
e-commerce experiences,
like a full featured date
picker, search auto-complete,
and web packaging for URLs.
And finally, WebAssembly
now has broad support
across browsers
and devices, making
it possible to run high
performance, low level
code written in many languages.
And that's the web.
Bye.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Meggin.
Jumping over to material design,
Yasmine, what's the latest?
YASMINE EVJEN: Well,
Timothy, there's
a lot of great updates today.
Material design
is a design system
that can help you build
beautiful, usable products
across platforms.
And today, we've expanded
Material with our biggest
ever update to the
system, including
a new suite of
tools that help you
at every stage of the design
and development process.
Material theming is a new
capability of the Material
system that enables you
to express your brand's
unique identity using color,
type, and shape consistently
across your products.
Today, we also released
a suite of tools
that make it easier to go
from design to implementation.
The Material theme
editor helps you
create your own
branded Symbol Library
and apply global style
changes to color, shape,
and typography.
Currently available
for Sketch, you
can access the
Material theme editor
by downloading the
Material plug-in.
You can then share
that work easily using
Gallery, a tool for
collaborating on design work,
getting feedback, and tracking
iterations all in one place.
Optimized for Material,
Gallery generates
interactive red lines,
developer documentation,
and design parameters
for Material components.
And finally, we want to make
this all really easy for you
to build and code, so our open
source material components
for Android, iOS, the
Web, and Flutter all
support Material theming today.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very cool.
Thanks, Yasmine.
Now on to machine learning.
Magnus, what's up with ML?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Well, Timothy,
our vision for AI at Google
is to turn the latest technology
into products that empower
developers and end users.
We heard about a few new
things, including cloud TPUs.
They are now
available to everyone.
Just head over to g.co/cloudtpu.
AutoML is another exciting area.
It automates the creation
of machine learning models.
Our first widely
available release
will be AutoML
vision, which makes
it possible to recognize images
unique to your applications
without writing any model code.
We're looking forward
to bringing AutoML
to more machine learning
tasks very soon, as well.
And of course, TensorFlow--
we recently announced
TensorFlow.js,
which brings machine learning
to millions of web developers
through JavaScript.
You can also create new models
in the browser, or as well
on the server side,
through null.js.
Also, models can be run
with a webGL acceleration.
Oh!
And we brought TensorFlow
to Edge devices,
including Android
and iOS mobile phone,
with TensorFlow light, which
also now supports Raspberry Pi.
In addition, we
released ML Kit in beta.
ML Kit is an SDK that
brings Google's machine
learning capabilities to mobile
developers through Firebase.
And speaking of Firebase, I'm
sure you'll want to hear more
from Jen about this topic.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Magnus.
Hey, Jen, let's talk Firebase,
and of course, ML Kit.
JEN PERSON: In the
past few months,
we've brought Crashlytics,
Fabric's flagship crash
reporter into Firebase.
With the combination of
Crashlytics, performance
monitoring, and
Google Analytics,
Firebase really helps you
better understand and improve
your apps.
I'm also really excited about
how we've been introducing ML
to Firebase.
One example is with
Firebase Predictions,
which predicts the future
behavior of your users,
allowing you to take proactive
actions to optimize your app.
This is something that can be
useful for a variety of things
like A/B testing, sending
offers to specific users,
and changing the
difficulty of a game,
depending on users'
retention levels.
And of course, as
Magnus mentioned,
ML Kit is now available
in public beta.
With it, we're bringing
ML tech from across Google
and making it available to
mobile developers for Android
and iOS.
My favorite API
is image labeling,
which helps identify
objects like trees, dogs,
and Google I/O attendees.
And since ML Kit is
available through Firebase,
it's easy to take advantage
of the rest of the Firebase
platform, like storing your
image labels in Cloud Firestore
or experimenting with
different custom models
using A/B testing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Jen.
OK, one more topic.
Hey, Fred, let's talk
about augmented reality.
FRED SAUER: You
know, I first want
to start by saying I
think augmented reality is
one of those really exciting
advances in mobile computing.
It allows us to all interact
with digital content
and information in the
context of the real world.
And we can do it on
the devices that we
have with us every single
day in our pockets.
At least most of us do.
Well, there's kind
of three things
I want to highlight
from the keynote,
all about AR Core, which
is Google's platform
for building the augmented
reality experiences.
First, we heard
about Scene Form.
It's a brand new 3D framework,
physically based render that's
optimized for
mobile, and it really
makes it easy for
Java developers
to build augmented
reality applications.
The SDK has everything that
you need, as a developer,
to start building those
3D experiences right
into your apps.
There's an Android Studio
plug-in that's currently
in beta, and that helps
you important preview
3D assets right
in Android Studio,
and works with your workflow.
We also heard about
augmented images.
That makes it possible to attach
digital content and experiences
to images in the real world.
And I went to images.
It doesn't just detect images,
but it lets you continuously
attach content appropriately,
because it gives you
the precise location,
orientation of those images,
and then you, as a developer,
place your content right
where you want it.
And then finally, we
heard about Cloud Anchors.
Air Course Cloud
Anchors are just--
I think they're really
exciting because they allow
multiple devices to have
a shared understanding
and context of the real world.
So multiple users can get
together on their phones,
and they can see and interact
with the same digital content,
and it's all anchored to the
world in exactly the same way.
Now, Cloud Anchors are
available for Android and iOS,
so developers can build those
cross-platform, shared AR
experiences that we
all want to have.
And of course, all
of these AR Core
features-- they're
available for use today.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Fred.
All right, everyone.
Your first sessions
will be starting
at the top of the hour.
Remember to stay with
us after your session
ends to get your first look
at the sandbox with Lorena.
She'll be taking you
over to the Android Dome
to see what's new with
Android TV and Android Play.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]